[Music]
[Applause]
they bring in Jalen Rose see what I deal
with every day Jim I mean somehow I make
magic here but uh
dayless Soul uh did you ever see uh
George Clinton did you ever see
Parliament
absolutely I'm the youngest of four and
just so you know
I was born in 73 and I remember my
childhood and just seeing the Smoke Rise
From the basement and going downstairs
and my brothers had these red and blue
police lights and these streamers coming
from the ceiling where I was an
Uninvited Guest in my own house
and I started to realize with a lot of
those records meant and one time I took
one of those clips
with the
um the the
um the feather on the end the roach clip
kind of exactly and put it on my pants
and took it to school one day and I
definitely got in trouble for doing so
because I didn't know what it was so
absolutely
Parliament Afrika bambaata towards
Clinton all of those groups were heavily
a part of my childhood what was the
smoke that was coming out of the
basement
oh it just had a different smell than it
was a tobacco
uh let me give you a few just to call it
reefer back in the day I guess uh ESPN
NBA analyst and uh the 13th overall pick
by the nuggets
yes indeed 1994 1994 uh Jalen will be
part of the Boston Celtics all access
tomorrow wall-to-wall coverage of the
team followed by the Cavs Celtics at 7
30 Eastern I've been talking about
LeBron's injury he said he stepped on
somebody's foot it but he didn't like
what do you see with that injury and
it's always tricky for any athlete to
have a foot injury
absolutely it's a recurring theme for
him first and foremost he dealt with a
foot injury already it looked like his
takeoff was a little awkward when he
landed he didn't want to put any
pressure on the injured foot and he's 38
years of age Dan yeah he still finished
the game the Lakers had an amazing
comeback in a win at Dallas and I'm
pretty sure that pain that soreness
um continues to permeate now obviously
if he's going to miss x amount of games
and x amount of weeks that's gonna Doom
their playoff potential but I admire
LeBron how he's performed this year
um being becoming the NBA's all-time
leading scorer leading that Lakers team
that while they're on the Marquee when
you look put on some binoculars and you
look closer at the standings they're
still like 13th so I applaud him for
what he's tried to do for that club all
year I saw where ESPN has draft rankings
and Ronnie James is a top 10 ranking
right now and I mean that was quick
because I thought he was you know maybe
in the top 30 or 40 in his class and I
don't know is this wait a Wishful
ranking to put Ronnie in there as a top
10 pick
for the draft what a what a one thing
about sports is if it's wishful or not
you still have to get out there and play
against the best of the best and I've
watched
him grow as an athlete as a player
improve his strength improve his
athleticism improve his jump shot
improve his handle
when he was younger it it almost feels a
little as a former player and obviously
doing this job for a living
what line do we draw at covering these
young players so are we going to say top
fifth grader top seventh grader that
feels a little
predatory to me but now as he's gotten
into high school and become a McDonald's
All-American a legit candidate for uh
for the status that you just acknowledge
is fair to cover him and cover him
righteously and I think it's well
deserved
talking to Jalen Rose you know what I
noticed a lot of times we'll look at a
game and there's a big comeback and
we'll go is this about the team that
lost the lead or the team that ended up
coming back Lakers against the Mavericks
one thing that stood out is Lucas got to
stop complaining about every call Jalen
like I mean I'm sure he gets a handful
of calls every game but man does he
whine
it's not just Luca Dan it's most of the
players in the league actually complain
after every call one of the things I
learned as a player just think about
this each time the whistle is blown
the team that receives the call and
their fan base is Happy the the the
opposite happens when it goes against
you you never seen a player say you know
what that was a weak call that was a bad
call I don't want to shoot these free
throws
I had to raise my hand when I found
somebody maybe like 24. all right even
if I didn't think I found him I'd raised
my hand up now they don't do that now
that's definitely changed in the game
but I'll tell you what as dominant as
Luca has been so very young in his
career the one thing that I saw from the
mass that I did not like
I don't like to see the best players
taking turns
to try to get off I like to see them
working together to make each other
better
so adding Kyrie shouldn't mean he and
Luca play together but then one has to
be out of the game for the other one to
really be at their Apex and that played
itself out in that game and that's why
they ended up losing
there's a documentary about Mahmoud
Abdul rauf who I thought had the
quickest handle
prior to when he was Chris Jackson at
LSU before he changed his name that was
quickest handle I'd ever seen and then
you got Kyrie
and Kyrie's probably got the best handle
in the history of the sport would you
say
he's in the conversation
I always wondered growing up
what what it would be like if the Harlem
Globetrotters played in the NBA like
what if Marcus Haynes or Curly Neal
played in the NBA and two guys that
remind me of the two guys I just
mentioned are Steph Curry and Kyrie
Irving the Wizardry they both have with
the basketball the ability to jump off
both feet finish with both hands and we
talk about their great ball handling but
the the beauty to both of their games is
how they're able to shoot with range and
accuracy and Steph Curry in particular
has taken it to a whole nother level and
to be guys that are considered slighter
built based on the players that they're
playing against how they're able to
finish at the hoop so yes when you start
talking about greatest handles Kyrie's
definitely in the conversation Isaiah
Thomas of my Detroit Bad Boys definitely
has to be in that conversation as well
and and rightfully so Kyrie deserves
that acclaim did you go to Pistons games
growing up
well what had happened was the ticket
prices
and then they were playing in Pontiac
for a while at the silver dome which if
you grew up in Detroit that you got a
better chance to get into Chicago than
you do to the silver Dome so to speak
and then they moved to Auburn Hills and
so I didn't physically get a chance to
go to games when I was young but I did
watch all of the games on a on a 13-inch
television sitting on top of a component
set you know about those with the 33 and
the 45 in the thimble yeah and so I
remember and when Sacramento and the
Clippers just played a game it literally
and they like the second highest scoring
game in the history of the league it
took me back to my childhood because I
remember staying up late and watching
the highest point score in the history
of the game Isaiah Thomas John Eddie
Long Kelly tripucka playing at Denver
Alex English Kiki vandaway I was
physically watching that game on channel
62 in the legendary George Blaha was
calling that game and so as I started to
get older obviously I had a chance to go
to the games and my father got drafted
by the Pistons but season tickets wasn't
in the budget
did you grow up hating Michael Jordan
absolutely
two places that never cheered for Jordan
and celebrated really wearing his shoes
fortunate enough I grew up in Detroit
that was one and played in Indiana
that's two and this is where rivalries
were real and when the Pistons finally
beat the Bulls
I'm sorry when the book when the Bulls
finally beat the and by the way Isaiah
Thomas is the only human being to have a
winning record against magic bird and
Jordan with that being said when the
Bulls finally beat my bad boys Pistons
there was a moment in sports that people
look at it through a couple of different
lenses
we walked off the court and didn't shake
their hands you can't tell me I wasn't
in that line with them you you cannot
tell me that I wasn't walking off with
them and that was a sense of Pride that
we had as Champions and our entire city
love and beloved that team to this day
and that was a beautiful rivalry Bad
Boys versus the Chicago Bulls and MJ
help me understand this JJ Redick
controversy that he's he's talking about
today's game and if you talk about
yesterday's game you didn't want to hear
about physicality uh Dominic Wilkins got
into this and said that you know that JJ
redick's take was idiotic I think here
it was more physical back in the day
because you could use the arm bar and I
could put my hand on you start there
it's got to be more physical but I don't
know why JJ has a problem with yesterday
I believe if if you really just look at
how the rules have changed the main
difference in past basketball in today's
basketball is physical intimidation does
not exist
period it does not exist and so when you
know you can drive to the basket and not
have to get peeled up off the floor
seven or eight times a game what does
that do it affects your endurance
because falling on the floor for 82
games sticks or seven times a game means
you can't play 15 to 20 years that means
you may be lucky to play 10 to 15 years
also that physical intimidation we
talked about look no further than the
Jordan rules
Michael Jordan had to understand that I
need to get stronger I need to improve
my jump shot because if I go flying
through the air with my tongue hanging
out they're gonna knock me to the floor
and this is what I want to say about
when people compare the old to the new
of course an iPhone is better than a
pager
of course it is
but that doesn't mean that at the time
when we were using pagers or flip phones
they didn't mean everything
they meant everything at that time yes
technology is better and yes the players
are more skilled now Dan can dribble
pass and shoot they specialize they
shoot with better range but look no
further than what's in an error position
basketball look at the four or the power
forward
that guy used to actually be powerful
and physical yeah right yeah now that
guy is a a player that's six eight 230
pounds that played shooting guard or
small forward in high school
that's now playing that position and so
that's where the game has changed the
physicality of the game
um doesn't exist from an intimidation
standpoint and also players skill level
is is at an ultimate maximum that we
haven't seen
how badly are you rooting for somebody
to score 82 points in a game
I don't I don't care really
um and and the thing is rest in peace to
the Black Mamba like I grew up in the
game and I respect the game and when you
get a chance to watch greatness go
against greatness and compete against
greatness you're gonna be on the wrong
side of it and respectfully like I said
in a fab five doc
when we lost in the final four
when we went out after the game we
wasn't waiting in line the team that
beat us was to get into the spot
and I also said that you can't tell me
the last three or five NCAA Champions so
I'll ask you this we saw Donovan
Mitchell score 71.
we saw Dame Lillard score 71.
but none of those players
are going to be I guess as attached to
those games as I am to the Kobe game
respectfully because I'm famous
that's really what it is Jalen is a
common name my mother created a name
that's a common name and so of course if
and when people think they're trying to
clown me they'll bring that up but at
the same time I respect the game I love
and miss Kobe Bryant and news flash it
ain't 100. you've got the record the
record is 100 everybody so when
everybody started talking about who's
the greatest scorer and who's the record
is 100. do we know who was playing
against will no
uh nobody was apparently that night uh I
I love that I love that see I would
rather compete it's like when you have
the mercy rule like I don't want a mercy
rule if you if you if you put up a
number on me I gotta get better I it's
not hey you got to help me because my
feelings and not that they do this in an
NBA game but as you said to me before I
didn't guard him the whole game so they
make it seem like you had Kobe the
entire game and he put up 81 on you
well one day I'll get up they kind of
broke down like the stats of what
happened in the game yeah and he
actually scored 18 points on me
and the funny thing about an NBA game
that happens to players on a nightly
basis
literally when somebody scores 18 points
on them and so again if you're around
long enough and you get a chance to
compete against greatness some of the
times you're on the wrong side of Brady
Thorne six or seven touchdowns or
you know Michael Jordan putting up a
historic game or Steph Curry making you
know 10-3 pointers in the game it just
it's going to happen and it happened to
me it happened to our Raptors and and
and and and I'm actually glad it was
Kobe Bryant because this is the same
Kobe Bryant by the way
that wouldn't be low manager yeah
yeah okay and so that should be the guy
that has the second highest scoring game
in the history of the NBA so you locked
up Kobe is what you're saying
yeah
no you
mean one of your teammates walking
around going man I hope they don't break
this down and uh you know I gave up 40
to Kobe you gave up just 18. hey great
to talk to you as always Jalen thanks
for sharing and uh good luck with the uh
all access with the Celtics yes sir I
appreciate the love as always that's
Jalen Rose Boston Celtics all access
tomorrow wall-to-wall coverage on the
mothership followed by Cavs Celtics at 7
30 Eastern back after this